hi welcome to another episode of Cold
Fusion
only a couple of years ago China was on
the path to overtaking the United States
and becoming the world's largest economy
in 2014 many were speculating that this
could happen as soon as 2024
dubbed by many as an economic Miracle
China Grew From a third world country to
a global superpower in just a matter of
a few decades
few could foresee the effects that the
economic reform in the late 1970s would
have on the developing country
soon the lists of the largest companies
in the world began to feature more and
more Chinese Enterprises globally the
country was one of the most important
trade Partners fueling globalization on
a scale never seen before and with that
power came influence
fast forward a few years and China finds
itself in a myriad of problems both
economic and political a catastrophic
zero covered policy real estate debt
crisis external infrastructure issues
internal debt issues a mini Revolt of
the youth and the slowing down of the
economy are just some of the things that
have been plaguing the nation recently
the results of these issues threaten the
very power structures of the country so
how did China get here and what are the
consequences for the country and the
world as a whole so get comfortable
buckle up and get ready for a wild ride
[Music]
let's begin by understanding the most
talked about issue the real estate
bubble
the main growth both for the Chinese
economy as well as the housing market
began in 1979 with economic reform
From Here China opened up to the rest of
the world
massive civilian migration from rural
locations to main city hubs ensued as
people look to improve their quality of
life
hundreds of millions of sons and
particularly Daughters of Chinese
farmers who move from the farm where
they were earning really the same as
they were earning a thousand years ago
in Chinese history absolute subsistence
wages they traveled four or five hours
to the local city and there they began
working in the big factories the
workshop of the world
due to that in four decades China went
from a mostly rural population to a
country where two-thirds of the entire
population lives in major city hubs on
top of relocations a cultural element
also boosted the sales of housing owning
real estate was considered a source of
financial stability for a family as well
as a prerequisite for marriage
out of the one child policy and the
Chinese preferring male heirs
they are 35 million more men than women
in China
that creates intense competition for
brides with men often having to prove
their material worth this often means
owning a home this led to entire
families and their friends pooling money
to contribute to the purchase of a house
for their relatives why you might ask
because the prices of Apartments have
gotten so out of control that according
to the financial times housing
affordability in China is among the
worst in the world taking into account
living expenses it would take the
average earner 50 years to buy an
apartment
this Collective pooling of money is a
major difference between the Chinese
property market and the West
little inventory and slow development
combined with rapid growth led to Major
supply issues thus Prices rose and
affordable housing became an issue for
local governments
the solution was to issue loans to
property development companies as well
as easing the credit lending standards
to individuals due to these factors the
Chinese real estate market became a
rocket ship and it fueled massive
economic growth some companies like the
infamous evergrant took full advantage
of the situation and expanded
aggressively aided in a large part by
the availability of cheap credit
evergrand became so large that they even
built a theme park and purchased a
soccer team with some of the money
the theme park is now abandoned you'll
see why shortly but here's how it looks
like now
it really is a sad waste of money time
and resources
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
many of these property institutions
quickly became the largest in the
country and many expanded projects into
overseas markets
commercial housing sales reached 2.7
trillion dollars in 2020.
in China today the general population
has about 70 percent of their total
wealth stored in the real estate market
let me repeat that 70 of their total
wealth is stored in the real estate
market
however the supply of housing was still
short in part due to speculation it was
commonplace to purchase a second or
third home as an investment since it was
considered wise and a stable use of
savings
seeing the never-ending demand
developers created an ingenious system
to further fuel expansion
these were based on two key pillars
first they started to finance their
operations with foreign debt the
appetite for Chinese debt and Equity was
increasing around the world since their
massive growth brought very attractive
yields secondly developers created
pre-sale options for buyers that quickly
became the norm in the country
in it home buyers would give money to
Developers for a home that has yet to be
built all they had was a promise that
once it was finished it would be theirs
the whole construction period would take
about two to three years usually
and people will start uh paying their
mortgage way before the completion of
the project
years even years or maybe yeah over a
year over a year and a half
in the past it wasn't seen as a risky
business because as I said and people
would not expect developers cannot
complete their home at a large scale not
like now while this made sense for both
sides it quickly escalated with loose
regulations around how much money the
property developers needed to keep they
started to game the system to their
advantage
by obtaining pre-sales they were able to
start new projects without finishing the
old ones once the new projects yielded
new pre-sales they would use some of
that money to finance the actual
construction while the rest went to new
projects and so on
in essence they created a Ponzi scheme
that relied 100 on the stable and
Perpetual growth of the housing market
however once the influx of people to
major cities started to slow down from
4.1 to 1996 to 2.1 percent in 2020 the
scheme started to fall apart
with a Slowdown in pre-sales developers
started to rely more and more on Banks
and foreign debt to keep expanding
sometimes the debt payment was too large
to pay with an operating income so they
used further debt to finance their
obligations it all continued for some
time but soon the Chinese authorities
entered the scheme
in August of 2020 the Chinese government
implemented the three red lines policy
each line represents a debt ratio that
the companies had to respect if not
their ability to contract more
liabilities was severely hampered
developers with extreme amounts of debt
such as evergrant crossed all three
lines meaning that they were not able to
increase their liabilities any further
and since evergrant used debt to finance
old liabilities it was not long before
they started to run into liquidity
troubles
first they failed to repay the wealth
managers who had a direct investment in
the company and this provoked a large
Revolt by wealth managers and investors
who went to their headquarters to
protest in September 2021 there was a
hugely crucial moment over Grand missed
payments on wealth management products
the wealth management Market in China as
well Ordinary People can put their
savings and the money is usually going
into real estate often to companies like
Evergreen and these people who had
invested hadn't got their money back
they descended on the headquarters of
overground in xinjiang
we don't know where to get our money and
now we we go to Shenzhen government and
nobody help us
this was the point of which went from it
might be a crisis to well it probably is
a crisis
soon after evergrant started to fail on
its payments of dollar bonds and these
Bonds were sold to the Western world
and they weren't the only property
company in trouble
property developer caser missed a 400
million Bond payment in November of
2021.
and in January of 2022 shimayo group
defaulted on a 101 million dollar loan
and most recently The Uso group
requested to defer a payment of offshore
bonds worth 582 million
this resulted in a large loss of
confidence in the Chinese housing and
bond market both internally and
externally this accumulated in mortgage
strikes by distinguished buyers who were
paying their monthly bills without
seeing any progress on their purchase
property
to date more than 320 groups of
homeowners are believed to be refusing
to pay their mortgage loans
[Applause]
Chinese are home buyers as property
developers hold construction on their
homes
since July Home Buyers Say in over 100
cities across China have declared a
mortgage boycott just like Tim many home
buyers are desperate some have taken to
Street demonstrations but these have
been quickly quashed with officials
citing covet concerns
backed into a corner home buyers that
have threatened to stop payments on
their mortgage in over 300 projects
the value of these loans is estimated to
be worth between 150 and 300 billion
dollars
the Chinese government has since
slightly relaxed the rules and on top of
that the Chinese Central Bank has cut
interest rates in an attempt to revive
the credit and housing markets we'll
have to see what happens with this it's
not clear if the situation will subside
or if more property developers go
unsolvent causing civil unrest
on top of all of this real estate
related activities represent close to 30
percent of total Chinese yearly GDP
if the property sectors go under there's
going to be a ripple effect it's a risk
to Banks local governments and the
stability of China
while all of that might sound bad enough
other debt issues are starting to rear
their ugly head there's been many
unprofitable and huge debt-ridden
infrastructure projects one famous case
is the super speed railroad
the infrastructure project began after
the 2008 financial crisis as an attempt
to pump money into the economy and
create employment opportunities
it was a classic fiscal policy boost
that worked to Perfection the project
was a major success offering employment
to millions and single-handedly pushed
some industry sectors such as steel and
concrete out of default
this was in large part why China avoided
the turmoil that most other countries
faced during the 2008 crisis
while it did save the economy from
recession the problems started right
after construction finished
since the railway connected secondary
locations and not main destinations the
demand was not always there
and to add to this the ticket prices
were Out Of Reach for the majority of
the population the lack of Revenue may
not have been an issue however this
project was funded by massive amounts of
debt by Major Banks local governments as
well as some publicly issued bonds
from 2015 up to this day the interest
alone on these payments have surpassed
the operating income of the project
that's right the interest on the debt
has been more than the company's income
as of 2021 their total liabilities of
5.9 trillion Yuan or 900 billion dollars
in other words five percent of the
Chinese GDP the majority of these
liabilities are bonds which were sold to
State Banks
thanks to the zero covered lockdowns the
rail infrastructure is being used even
less as a response the Chinese
government announced an economic
stimulus to lift the covert hit economy
this included allowing the China Railway
to issue another 300 billion yuan in the
form of Railway construction bonds the
doubling down on an already unprofitable
Venture it seems like China is putting
appearances above functionality and
profitability
a path that can lead to major issues if
not addressed accordingly
due to massive amounts of debt expansion
profit motives and poor planning there
are numerous ghost cities in China these
are areas of vast amounts of
infrastructure and property that
virtually remains unoccupied the
financial times explains
the ratio of empty apartments in China
could range between 10 percent and as
high as 40 or even 50 percent in some
small cities there are enough empty
homes in China right now to house about
90 million people greater than the
population of Germany or the UK newer
developments were built quite quickly
without a lot of consideration for yeah
the logistics I've traveled to many
parts of China where you go to a suburb
and suddenly you see this Forest of
apartment blogs
carry on for five ten minutes in your
taxi and you're still going through
apartment block after apartment block
with nobody in them I visited one of the
most more famous ghost cities odos in
the middle of the desert very far away
from anything it was quite strange
because it's not like there's
necessarily jobs there
foreign
to add to the internal debt issues China
is also struggling with external
infrastructure projects
the grand belt and Road initiative is
threatening to turn out to be one of the
most unprofitable Global projects of all
time
the initiative is a large investment
into more than 100 countries it's
China's ambitious attempt at growing
Global influence as well as creating
Global links to China in theory
strengthening its import export markets
the thing is though investment in Risky
countries is just that risky and if not
calculated properly these Investments
can turn out to be very unprofitable
Ventures
in just 2020 and 2021 China has had to
renegotiate more than 52 billion dollars
in debt
and a lot of the countries that China
deals with are unwilling or unable to
pay
the Belson Road initiative has become so
large that China has become the world's
largest source of development credit
overtaking the World Bank as well as the
IMF considering that this project is
political in nature no matter how
unprofitable the state government is
likely to keep financing it
China could gain Untold geopolitical
leverage but it comes with the risk of a
catastrophic outcome both for the
financial stability of China as well as
causing a political debacle due to its
involvement in other countries foreign
affairs
[Music]
as if debt issues both on the internal
and external front are not enough the
Chinese government continues to support
a zero covert policy to this day
the plan on paper was to eliminate the
disease the government was to be seen as
competent and to be able to deal with
whatever came its way and it worked for
some time
as of today according to the official
statistics the death toll from the virus
in China stands at little over five
thousand while the US is over 1 million
no matter how staged these numbers might
be the authorities could point to this
low number as a rationale for lockdowns
while the rest of the world is moving on
due to herd immunity China on the other
hand can't do so they've had no natural
immunity
the latest mandate is for every major
city to have a test site like this
within 15 minutes walk of every resident
it looks like they're going to become a
permanent fixture on the streets and
having a negative result will be
required for going to school work
shopping or eating out
there will be no living with the virus
in China
it is pursuing a pandemic victory at all
costs
once they announced the zero covert
policy and how it could go on for more
than five years the lockdown's
perception in the general population's
eyes quickly changed
people are now protesting lockdowns in
what can only be described as a
dystopian nightmare
thank you
however even if the state wanted to
going back on its policies now would be
a complete disaster both on a
humanitarian and political scale
according to shanghai's Fudan University
the death toll could reach more than one
million people and it would be an
admission of failure on the part of
State leadership completely unacceptable
as the government is preparing for its
20th party Congress where current
president Xi Jinping will go on for his
third consecutive term as party leader
thus having a Slowdown of the economy
and popular discontent seemed to be no
matter how wrong the only viable path
for the state authorities moving forward
if they backtrack its weakness and
saving face is a big part of Chinese
culture and the government must showcase
their superiority no matter how staged
it might seem to their Western
counterparts
what does this mean for the economy well
to start a massive decline in internal
demand and increasing employment
especially among the Young
for educated young people one-fifth of
themselves find themselves jobless at
the time of recording
on the external front the zero covert
policy has been one of the main issues
fleeting into the global recession
there's been a weakening of confidence
of foreign businesses that rely on China
for exports and imports
the most extreme example is Apple who is
moving some of their manufacturing of
the iPhone 14 to rival India and we've
done a full episode on this story
the economic and political issues are
not the only problems for the state
government either increasing
unemployment among the young and
educated is quickly on the rise climbing
to a record 20 in July of this year
this is mainly due to the slowing down
of the economy and the shrinking
opportunities that come with it
in my 2021 episode on the great
resignation we touched on the popular
online movement called Tang ping or lie
flat basically it was an online movement
of Youth that decided to stop playing
the rat race stop climbing that
corporate ladder and just to take things
more slowly
but now in 2022 this has evolved into
something new a more extreme movement
known as Bailon or to let it rot
these youth have completely decided to
give up on the system and are just doing
the bare minimum to get by
it's a complete shock to the older
generation of Chinese who have never
seen anything like this in their
lifetime the byline youth believe that
there's nothing to be gained by working
hard and putting in extra effort isn't
going to result in reward
it didn't take long for the Chinese
government to take notice in May of 2022
president Xi Jinping in a speech to the
entire nation emphasized the importance
of young people and their contributions
to the country as a whole stating that
quote China's hopes lie in youth
reducing inequality and improving
opportunities has been their main
priority for some time and yet the
measures taken such as cracking down on
big Tech and banning private school
tutoring so far have not helped the
situation much
[Music]
so the preceding was a brief summary of
what's been going on in China
there was plenty that wasn't said we
didn't even get to the Rural Bank runs
we're around 400 000 people aren't able
to access their life savings but you get
the idea so other click bait titles on
YouTube true is China going to implode
well the answer is more complicated than
that it seems clear that China is
putting its political agenda in front of
Economic and humanitarian situations
the stubbornness of the ruling class has
caused China to be in an uncomfortable
position
a seemingly Unstoppable Nation suddenly
has major cracks appearing in multiple
places cracks that need to be patched
with more than a Band-Aid solution
the major threat across all of these
topics covered is a loss of confidence
by its people in the state government
and getting that confidence back will be
a difficult challenge perhaps the most
likely outcome may be a slow grinding
recession and political upheaval in the
coming years
But ultimately it's too complicated of
an analysis for anyone to give a
definite answer but there's definitely
more work that needs to be done to keep
things from escalating further and for
the people to trust their government
again
one thing is sure the next few years for
China carry a lot of risk and whether
things get a lot worse or not depends on
how the situation is handled by the
Chinese government
but what about the rest of the world
well for the rest of the world these
problems in China will certainly have
major Ripple effects especially for
those who rely directly on the import
export Market of China we can expect the
inflationary Trend to continue as
Chinese Supply diminishes
for the United States this means 20 of
the total Imports can be affected
on top of that the growing
deglobalization Trend will make prices
higher as more countries bet on local
production and that means less cheap
labor
for some economies like Australia where
I'm from we might be in a lot of trouble
because Australia's exports to China
account for about 65 percent of total
trade that's a massive exposure risk and
as most Australians would know we don't
really have that many other trading
partners that could back up such a loss
specific Industries will also see major
setbacks case in point is the EV battery
sector the Chinese lithium-ion Global
battery production was 76 while there
are constant efforts by the European and
U.S governments to increase their
production the Stark truth is that China
is a massive trading partner that can't
be replaced on short notice
lastly it's also important to mention
the investment exposure that many
countries have to Chinese debt and
equities
this includes many investment firms in
Europe and the us not to mention all the
funds that have suffered losses from the
numerous delisting of Chinese equities
over the past few months on top of that
China's slowdown could mean more
difficulty for the US to issue debt
since China is the second largest holder
of U.S treasuries
on the positive side less demand for
fuel
China Imports 80 of its needs and is
going to put some downward pressure on
prices giving a little help to the
energy crisis now and a small downward
force on the input costs on basically
every good produced
overall the interconnectedness between
Global markets has been the engine of
growth for some time
both in Achilles heel and the key to
economic prosperity of this Century a
recession in one major economy means a
global slowdown for the rest of the
world
it will be very interesting to witness
the changes that happen will this change
global trading in the future will
globalization continue to be a trend or
after this will countries tend to look
more Inward and will production be more
localized
whether it's the Outlook of China or the
global economy as a whole only time will
tell
so what do you guys think feel free to
discuss in the comments section below
before I go just one final note in the
last episode about the UK economy there
are a lot of comments gloating about the
situation and rejoicing I think it's
worth noting that a distinction should
be made between a nation's government
and the innocent civilians who don't
deserve to suffer when things start
going wrong
this also applies to the citizens of
China it's never nice to see innocent
people suffer I just thought I'd make
that clear
if you did like this episode feel free
to take a look around the channel
there's plenty of interesting topics
here on Cold Fusion whether you're into
science technology or business and
finance
anyway thanks for watching my name is
[ __ ] and you've been watching cold
fusion and I'll see you again soon for
the next episode cheers guys have a good
[Music]
I thought
[Music]
I'll make it
[Music]
cold fusion it's me thinking